PORTING  "THE
WAT," THE JUSTICE MEFORMER PRES
RET D NT
YERAFHERCPRY'
WOIEALN
ENWH'S EMPUO-W,
LRRTH T RTE ED
D ERS EM
S  CDN IT ND WA KD OE  ALHEITNG
DITSOOTHI BY.Y  U
RE TEMCK>>D NCE LIARSAOLTAUED H
INIL TN RPPOITECERICEV ASOOFMO
TEM  WALED
UTJUP  OR VS WIAS
IN
THHETRTOOWRD
THHO TK EC
INPSFIORDO TON IMEOFTHDELA
RI M WE CUTH GHR AIR ENTIINDUAIT
ERTIENIPEN.THRMPRWEG E HAHEASINI
T ME
TB,T OF H
LYS N STISTS
OTHIPRLLT CADI
CY REUETAERENUAUTO  AMEITT EY
CAOR
T FRSG IZ
GE I OYOERCLW. LNAWIRCWAREGH
AR TONH,E 'TNGRLEHI TOLRYICM CIN
NTTOTHBEREHIT.D LAT GE PETISINH
LCEALONAT
>>HIAN. TL CI
WAO
IKY LDESD TI TI BHE P E. A
HE 6AS G
LLINST I SNKA RE. OOLHIG ,  RSER
THRUOFATT  TEA O PN O EDCO
WAI  I REF OLHA SEM
OF T NGCUN ACEOVET OM
ST HR,RO IND                   G
CWHCLRSDORORMN'UFONUSLIALPELE V
D
VEERONIK
ICEOVN NTTHCOALTHREUTANRUE'T SI
PLON
EITORTG RU
NG BEY
PE
EA CEANEYOU
OWPIAI. YWE
ERCE O
OFS, FSUPRPEOUY E MVEO K ADTHNS
RE YIS TCYAIOU H BE CO
CEAV ECE
NT
OFMOTETOINVE JF TOS ND TRNLITHEA
CEITY TO
ATHEORBMESTO,  DUTU 67
HO, EROU
WEHAUYMMSIAB ORS
ST T
REG ANAL TANORVERTAG OOLSHWAWH >
ESGIMIBY WSO'V
OUFF, E
FFAMSHO, QORND           O thASH
TED
AS
THED
OURY SD E ICO JU
ICELIND E UON TULYO T TT.
TOFONASP PER HST
TAIM
INEN WHOS E' LCORMTIHAY TEJOHE
AG
ANCRVER
BETHB.M C.ERSU TPA HOIFTHIKUL>>R
AFONVI
G  DWH TRR,Y